[Music]
when the Sun sets the activity level
rises in the RV park and troopers head
out to patrol the wild scene it's Friday
night
at Arctic man and they are getting ready
to just get it doesn't take officer Pete
Steen long to find one
this man was driving his snow machine
erratically yeah we do this in Kotzebue
one time I think so you're kind of
younger than you can take a normal
breath hold it for a second no chew in
your mouth nothing like that no gum
big steady breaths for me please
blow up and keep going blow harder net
keep going
point two four three yes
legal limits below eight so that's a
little over that's almost three times
the legal limit for troopers patrolling
the park discretion is the name of the
game many violations that would call for
citations on their normal beats may just
be a warning here at Arctic man
[Applause]
don't loan them it's a bead misdemeanor
in our presence we got their arrest
report deterrence is a big factor for us
we routinely have troopers in there
paired up visible so we can deter
anything
it's only 20 degrees but things heat up
just outside the bar a fight pulls in
every available trooper
trooper Jason Woodruff attempts to help
a victim of the scuffle but he doesn't
want it
who's giving you a friend
[Music]
they were trying to get him help and
spit blood everywhere and uh he spit on
me
spit spit blood on me I told him several
times that we're trying to get him help
and he spit blood on me and at that
point that's when we detained him and
took him to the ground and put handcuffs
on him to keep him from spitting any
more blood as you can see I got it in my
mouth of my face in my mouth was what
I'm most concerned about
I guess it's just a good thing we all
have to pay for the uniform